and go to the psych ward they were like
mr. Armstrong you've been here a ton of
times what could you possibly say to us
to make us think you're serious about
staying clean this time and I was like
I'm not here to detox I have a plan
to step in front of a train well I found
myself at the Huntington City Mission
homeless and parole completely addicted
to heroin I have a daughter you know she
see me under the fluence of heroin at a
public event and how I was so out of my
mind that even actually urinating myself
my daughter seen there
[Music]
I went to my parole officer and I cried
to her and I told her I don't have
anyone left at all she said you got me
JP and she reached across the table and
she gave me a fist phone all that
mattered was I at least have one person
and that gave me some hope it really
took me going to prison for the fourth
time in a work I need to do it you know
to find freedom I never forget laying on
a bunker insane to myself I needed to be
some changes in my life
recovery from addiction takes place in
basically two phases the first phase
entails what I call stabilizing a
patient this often but not always
involves medication so the first step of
recovery is stabilization at least the
person is standing still working on
getting the rest of his or her life in
order but then you have to draw the lens
out further so you've got someone who's
stable they're certainly not in
withdrawal but their life isn't really
much better and they don't see much of a
future for themselves and someone like
that is at risk for relapsing
[Music]
so I took advantage of every single
program available while I was in prison
that really helped me to do a lot of my
raw human emotion that I suppress
without all and other drugs and do that
inner work I needed to do in order to
Hill
once I got out started working I met a
great girl
and I was a cook at really nice seafood
restaurant I've been doing stand-up for
just over eight years now
I've got into a kind of on a whim I've
always wanted to do it after I got
myself together and I got sober I
developed and created a sober-living
program
[Music]
the thing about medically assisted
treatment is that there are some people
that that is as good as it's gonna get
for them I don't see it helping the
epidemic because these doctors that
prescribe it that's their go-to now
there's no hey can we try to get this
person you know regular treatment first
fortunately the route that I've was
given an opportunity to take did not
involve replacing one substance with
another and I don't want to just be
clean and sober to me that that's not
recovery one program that helped them
both was a drug treatment program within
the prison so after I finished the
program they hired me to be a peer
mentor and helping other enemies that
was incarcerated with me to deal with
their recovery and it gave me a sense of
purpose a very important part of
treatment and rehabilitation is getting
a person back to work work is so
important as therapy it provides a sense
of purpose it keeps people busy
well I'm a full-time father I work
full-time as a peer recovery specialist
today I'm a certified addiction recovery
coach my life is entirely all about
family and work
you know everyone expected me to die a
junkies death but today I'm a productive
member of society I'm a father and I do
my best to try to lead those kids down a
way to where they know that they can
talk about anything that's going on with
them
[Music]
you
[Music]